well palestinian islamic jihad is a
smaller armed group compared to hamas
which controls gaza the pij as it's
known is reported to have carried out
attacks inside israel for over 40 years
it was founded in the early 1980s by
palestinian activists in egypt the
group's aim is to create a
palestinian-islamic state within the
occupied west bank gaza and parts of
israel islamic jihad doesn't take part
in the palestinian political process it
rather concentrates on armed resistance
against israel through its military wing
the al kudz brigade it's active in gaza
and the occupied west bank
the group has its headquarters in syria
and also reportedly receives funds from
iran it is designated as a terrorist
group by the u.s eu israel and the uk
abu sada is an associate professor of
political science at al-azhar university
in gaza he says hamas has stayed out of
the conflict to avoid further escalation
hamas is in a very delicate position uh
at one thing that they are partners with
the islamic jihad
in in their resistance against the
israeli occupation and they are also
partners in what we call it the uh
mutual command in the gaza strip but in
the meantime hamas is feeling that if
they join the fighting with the islamic
jihad against israel israel will
intensify its bombing against
palestinian civilians and palestinian
infrastructure and also a headquarter of
security services in the gaza strip last
year israel waged a war for about 11
days which
inflicted massive
destruction on the
on the civilian infrastructure in the
gaza strip so this is the only concern
that uh probably deters hamas from
joining the fight against israel at this
moment that israel will take that as a
justification to kunu to continue its
bombardment and its destruction against
the civilian infrastructure in the gaza
strip now wither hamas has
uh the power
to to uh uh to put an end to the current
fighting between uh islamic jihad and
israel
i doubt that it seems to me that israel
has gone too far and israel has pushed
two red lines which would make it a a a
hard for hamas to convince the islamic
jihad to stop firing rockets against
israel i think it's going to take
countries like qatar or egypt or the
yuan to try to intervene and mediate an
immediate ceasefire between the islamic
jihad and israel